[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui une toute
nouvelle vidéo pour répondre à une
question doit-on acheter les nouveaux
macbook et macbook pro de 2017
et si oui lequel choisir c'est une
question qui m'a été posée par un jason
alors entre on a souvent besoin de
s'équiper d'acheter un nouvel ordi pour
ses études pour le travail apple annoncé
récemment une nouvelle mise à jour de sa
gamme de macbook et macbook pro que
faire lequel choisir on va essayer de
répondre à quelques questions
sans forcément rentrer dans les
spécifications techniques mais parlez
plus du côté pratique de vos réels
besoins
parce que la toute première question à
laquelle répond c'est quels sont vos
besoins on peut très bien acheter une
machine surboosté qui doit quand même
beaucoup temps et certains prix mais on
n'a pas nécessairement besoin
on sait que les produits apple sont de
bonne qualité par contre le coût est
très très très élevés par rapport à ceux
retrouvés sur la concurrence pour dès
qualité équivalentes
si on même apple si on veut la marque à
la pomme il faut mettre la main au
portefeuille et il faut débourser quand
même pas mal d'argent et sas augmente
dans le temps au temps moi j'ai acheté
mon macbook pro en 2011
j'ai dû le payer 1700 euros aujourd'hui
un macbook pro alors même si
effectivement une évolution en est sûre
du ssd en décembre d'autres choses
d'autres processeurs mais je dirais un
produit équivalent à l'époque
six ans plus tard il faut rajouter
presque 1000 euros si effectivement vous
voulez investir dans un produit de chez
apple sans forcément vous ruiner la
toute première question d'opposer sait
quels sont vos besoins est-ce que vous
avez des besoins je dirais de
bureautique somme toute assez classique
avec des gants guillemets faire du
traitement de texte aller sur internet a
retrouvé quelques applications mais rien
de bien gourmand quelque chose je dirais
que monsieur tout le monde va utiliser
si a contrario vous avez besoin d'un peu
plus de puissance vous faites de la
vidéo vous faites tourner en première
fête on a un final cut pro
vous faites du travail sur l'image mais
de l'image avec des grosses définition
car ils sont des fichiers raw vous
travaillez sur lightroom sans photoshop
sur le lustre accord vous faites du
multitâche vous avez plusieurs logiciels
qui vont tourner en même temps qu'ils
sont assez gourmand à ce moment là il va
falloir effectivement penser à avoir de
la mémoire vive et à avoir aussi des
grosses capacités de stockage autre
point si vous faites du gaming
même si on sait effectivement que la
plupart des gamers
super c'est parce qu'à des machines qui
sont très puissantes et beaucoup
beaucoup moins cher il ya quand même des
gamer sur mac donc si vous faire tourner
des jeux qui sont un petit peu gourmand
d'un point de vue graphique il faut
aussi se poser la question savoir si
vous comptez jouer oui ou non parce qu'à
ce moment là on va se diriger vers un
produit plutôt vers un autre un autre
point c'est de savoir combien
d'accessoires vous aider à brancher
parce que si vous êtes sur un macbook
pro 13 pouces
vous allez vous retrouver avec deux
ports thunderbolt roi alors que si vous
êtes sur un macbook pro 15 pouces
vous allez vous retrouver avec quatre
ports il ya aussi toute une
problématique à savoir si vous avez
besoin de brancher un écran 4 k 5 cas si
vous avez des accessoires le dernier
point qui ont un avis très important
c'est la question du stockage est ce que
vous avez besoin de stocker beaucoup de
données est-ce que vous avez beaucoup
d'informations à stocker ça fait aussi
partie de l'équation
si comme moi vous avez un mac qui est un
petit peu anciens moi j'ai mon macbook
pro 2011
il ya quelques temps j'ai rencontré les
vraies difficultés pour faire tourner
final cut dessus pour faire des montages
un petit peu plus long il ya dessus un
disque dur qui n'est pas du tout du ssd
il manquait cruellement de ram je me
suis posé la question de me dire est-ce
qu'il faut partir sur un nouveau macbook
pro mais quand j'ai vu les tarifs qui
sont quand même relativement prédictif
je me suis dit comment est ce que je
pouvais faire
il existe une solution qui est très
intéressante pour éviter d'acquérir un
nouveau macbook pro si vous en avez déjà
et que vous cherchez pas effectivement à
profiter du meilleur processeur il ya
trois choses que vous pouvez changer sur
ses vieux macbook pro le tout premier cd
disque dur passé sur un ssd
attention ne prenez pas des choses qui
vont être trop restreinte en termes de
mémoire de stockage
il faut prendre comme un disque dur avec
un petit peu de stockage si vous voulez
pas vous retrouver rapidement en bété et
bloqué un terrain ça serait super par
contre ça coûte rapidement très très
cher un petit discussions c'est crucial
vous le mettez dans votre mac ça
fonctionne parfaitement bien avec apple
vous pouvez le changez vous même il ya
plusieurs plutôt sur youtube vous
trouver très facilement
ça change tout simplement extrêmement
facilement la deuxième chose que vous
pouvez changer très facilement c'est
monter votre mémoire vive autre rame
d'origine j'avais deux barrettes
2 giga octet je suis monté avec deux
barrettes de 4 ce qui fait que
aujourd'hui j'ai quand même un
ordinateur qui est un petit peu plus
puissant et qui pour faire des calculs
somme toute basique 104 cas sur final
cut
ça marche très bien et la troisième
place que vous pouvez changer c'est la
batterie mais ça dans ce cas là on n'a
pas nécessairement besoin
si votre problématique est là si vous
n'avez pas des projets qui sont très
gourmands sur de la vidéo notamment de
la 4k ou des projections très long très
gourmand qui nécessitent d'être un gros
calculs vous embêtez pas booster un peu
la machine et ça fera l affaire il ya un
autre point qui pourrait être
intéressant si pour vous c'est d'acheter
un produit par le système du
reconditionnement d'apple le refurb
vous trouverez en bas sur leur site
propose des produits qui sont
reconditionnés des produits qui sont
très récents qui ont très peu servi
qu'on peut être envoyées à apple pour
des défauts il les corrige il était si
les remballer il voulait vendre à 15 20
% moins que ce que vous trouvez son
marché ça peut être super intéressant
avant de regarder un petit peu c'est
tout nouveau produit puis de voir un
petit peu à qui ils sont destinés il y à
un point qui est aussi très essentiel
c'est de penser à l'avenir et notamment
la revente parce qu'en réalité les
macbook et les macbook pro sont des
produits qui conserve quand même une
certaine valeur marchande et qui même au
bout de quelques années peuvent vous
rapporter un petit peu d'argent si vous
levant d'éboulements dans un prix somme
toute assez correct ça vous fait un
petit capital initial pour pouvoir
acheter une autre machine qui elle sera
forcément beaucoup plus cher donc si
vous achetez aujourd'hui un produit qui
est sur une fin de vie changent
totalement au macbook air qui sont
vraiment sur une fin de vie je vous
conseille pas du tout derrière dessus
vous allez perdre beaucoup d'argent même
si le produit vous l'avez acheté en 2017
et puis pensez aussi à l'avenir parce
que vos projets peuvent être de plus en
plus gourmands il va y avoir des
évolutions au niveau des programmes au
niveau des fichiers on va stocker des
fichiers de plus en plus importants
notamment sous fait de la vidéo
pensez à la 4k sauf que des fichiers en
quel cas c'est pas comme stocker du full
hd c'est très logique mais il faut y
penser donc penser vraiment à acheter
une machine avec une grosse capacité de
stockage pour ne pas le regretter parce
que aujourd'hui ce que la plupart des
gens regrette c'est d'avoir acheté des
disques durs en 128 giga et après ils
s'en mordent les doigts parce qu'il leur
manque vraiment du stockage si vous
faites de la photo redéfinition et de la
vidéo
finition est passée par là allez
directement sur des configurations qui
seront beaucoup plus importantes
donc il faut vraiment se poser un peu
toutes ces questions pour savoir où on
va pour savoir quel est le mac qui vous
correspond et quels sont vos besoins
avant de dire et de se jeter à corps
perdu sur le site d'apple ou autre et
d'aller dépenser votre argent d'ailleurs
si ça vous intéresse si un mac qui vous
intéresse je vous invite à les jeter
dans la description je vous invite
différents liens alors s'il ya de la
filiation si vous allez dessus et que
vous devez acheter un mac
je vous invite à passer directement par
ces liens parce qu'aujourd'hui - la
chaîne ne m'apporte aucune rémunération
ça permet effectivement de mettre un
petit peu de beurre dans les épinards
vingt mille investir un peu sur du
matériel donc si vous voulez acheter un
acte et que vous êtes convaincu allez
faire un tour dans la description on va
mettre dans tout regarder les différents
mac essaie d'analyser un petit peu le
rrq est intéressant pour vous lequel ne
l'est pas lequel vous correspond si oui
comment
allez on y va on va faire un peu
scolaire on va prendre comme à l'école
donc on a en réalité le choix entre cinq
machines macbook air 13 pouces macbook
12 pouces macbook pro 13 pouces macbook
pro 13 pouces avec la taxe bar el tap
jaidi que les macbook pro 15 pouces le
tout premier que je vous déconseille
fortement d'acheter c'est celui-là le
macbook air 13 pouces pourquoi parce que
macbook air on est sur des fins de
séries fans de gamme les produits
macbook air ne vont plus exister et sa
fondamentalement si vous l'achetez
alarmant ça voudra pas grand chose donc
on va faire une chose c'est qu'on va les
chasser
voilà comme à l'école c'est très
scolaire ensuite macbook 12 pouces
macbook 12 pouces avec un produit qui
est vraiment je dire assez compact si
vous vous déplacez beaucoup si vous
n'avez pas besoin de cuisson si vous
faites juste du traitement de texte
si vous voulez juste aller sur internet
un petit produit parce que vous aimez
l'environnement apple qui coûte pas
forcément cher mais par contre sur
lequel vous n'allez pas travailler pour
des projets qui sont lourds sur de la
vidéo sur la route sur des choses comme
ça ça c'est un produit qui prévalent
dans le coup ça peut être pas mal
ensuite les 13 pouces on arrive sur la
gamme pro la gamme pro un peu plus de
puissance mais on n'est pas sur le coup
de puissance ce qui est intéressant
c'est effectivement côté un peu plus
compact on a des écrans qui sont quand
même beaucoup plus petit il ya une vraie
différence entre les deux qui est mon
avis n'est pas une énorme différence sur
celui là vous avez une tête de ba et la
tâche
haili vous permettre de déverrouiller
facilement toutes les options de
navigation vous êtes en état de marche
ça reste aujourd'hui je dirais un peu du
gâchis
c'est pas ça qui l'a vraiment vous aider
dans votre navigation vous pouvez
utiliser sur fagnes alcl jeudi répond
david est un petit peu dans votre dans
votre dans votre barre en bas âge et
moins chez le terme excusez moi mais
voilà ça vous permet effectivement
naviguer un petit peu d'augmenter la
luminosité de l'abaisser mais vu la
différence de prix franchement ça vaut
pas le coup
après une différence de performances en
termes de processeurs savons pas
vraiment le coup très honnêtement si
vous voulez un macbook pro en 13 pouces
sur un petit écran
à mon sens du la différence de prix qui
est quand même assez conséquente
là on est quand même à 1499 sans la
coach bas et à 1999 avec la touch barre
donc un peu plus de puissance la
touchpad paul child dit vous avez 500
euros d'écart à mon avis ça sauf si vous
avez beaucoup d'argent auquel cas ils
pouvaient faire plaisir avec une tête
barre mais à mon avis c'est le gadget
qui coûte 500 euros pour le peu de
puissance que vous allez avoir il n'y a
pas une vraie différence macbook pro 15
pouces touch bartocci dit ça c'est le
produit pour usage professionnel de base
on à 2799 euros c'est un produit qui est
quand même très très cher si vous voulez
après la grève des montagnes des options
de puissance de stockage avec beaucoup
plus de choses vous pouvez le faire ça
c'est le produit à destination des
professionnels si vous n'êtes pas un pro
de l'image si vous n'êtes pas un pro
d'un photo un pro de la vidéo si vous
n'avez pas faire du multi applications
avec avec beaucoup de besoins
ça ne sert à rien d'aller là dessus
parce que ça va vous coûter très cher si
par contre vous avez besoin de faire de
la vidéo que vous voulez faire de la
vidéo en 4k que vous avez besoin de
faire tourner plusieurs applications
vous avez beaucoup de plugins ça il faut
passer par là là vous serez quand même
un petit peu léger et je vous dis il
faut penser à l'avenir passe aujourd'hui
c'est la 4k mais les définitions vont
continuer à monter
si vous achetez un mac book c'est un
macbook pro c'est au moins pour 5 ans
voire 10 ans d'utilisation
donc si vous avez un investissement à
frère sur du professionnel c'est un
macbook pro 15 pouces
si vous voulez faire un investissement
vous faire plaisir faire un petit peu de
vidéo mais sans utiliser forcément des
myriades de plugins le macbook pro 13
pouces sera la faire si vous voulez un
usage familial que vous voulez un
environnement mac vous prenez un macbook
12 pouces vol un petit peu il faut
vraiment voir ça comme trois types
d'utilisations l'utilisation familiale
l'utilisation semi-pro en faire un peu
de vidéo on veut essayer mais on n'a pas
de venir
professional yonhap a de très gros
besoins en termes de en terme de calcul
si on a besoin de beaucoup de calculs 15
pouces si vous voulez faire du jeu vidéo
15 pouces et ça ça va vous coûter 2 1799
euros minimum un autre point à prendre
en considération je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est qu'effectivement si vous
prenez un macbook pro 13 pouces vous
allez vous retrouver avec deux ports
thunderbolt roi sur votre machine qui va
vous servir pour la charge et pour
brancher vos usb c est après si vous
souhaitez tous les accessoires qui vont
être compatible avec il existe des hubs
pour pouvoir brancher plusieurs choses
sur mon ancien macbook on pouvait très
bien branché ici vous aviez une prise
dédiée ici pour la charge
vous aviez de l'usb vous avez lecteur de
cartes
vous aviez pas mal de pas mal de choses
qui aujourd'hui n'existe plus ça c'est
un petit peu dommage par contre il
existe des petits boîtiers des tubes qui
vous permet de brancher tout ça qui vont
vous coûter une petite somme mais après
vous serez vraiment tranquille par
contre sur un macbook pro 15 pouces vous
avez deux ports thunderbolt trois de
chaque côté
c'est pratique vous pouvez mettre votre
alimentation comme vous le souhaitez
vous pouvez brancher ce que vous
souhaitez comme vous voulez de chaque
côté c'est vrai que ça c'est quand même
pas mal
voilà un petit peu ce qu'on peut dire
pour résumer ces machines savoir un
petit peu comment se positionner quels
produits achetés je vous dis un truc qui
est essentiel quelques ordinateurs que
vous pourriez acheter
surtout ne vous plantez pas sur le
disque dur 128 gigas est trop petit vous
allez vous en mordre les doigts très
rapidement quand vous aurez des données
de stockage des photos des vidéos qui
vont grossir en volume et en taille de
fichier vous allez vraiment vous en
mordre les doigts
voilà un petit peu pour cette vidéo
merci d'avoir écouté j'espère que ça
vous aura intéressé que ça vous aura
aidé que ça vous rapporter quelques
quelques points de réflexion par rapport
à ce sujet et à ce choix
si ça vous intéresse n'oubliez pas
d'aller chercher dans la description je
vous ai ni des liens pour aller voir les
produits directement
n'hésitez pas aussi à vous abonner il ya
les saints joli coup si la vidéo vous a
pu essayer de vous apporter des
solutions
merci à vous et à très bientôt et d'ici
là vous portez vous bien
salut
[Musique]